hi there steve goffin here today i want
to talk about pronunciation because and
by the way the word is
pronunciation not pronunciation i
sometimes hear people say pronunciation
that's not the word it's pronunciation
but um
i'm doing that for a couple of reasons
first of all i i put out a blog post
where i said that uh
you know we don't need to
pretend or believe that we're gonna
sound like a native essentially we
really really do i've said this before i
can't i'm and yet people the people who
speak really well
are those that don't try to nail down
every last bit of native like
pronunciation you don't you don't have
to however we have to pronounce well
enough that people can understand us and
that it's not unpleasant to listen to it
has to be clear you don't want to be
asking a bigger partner what
what did you say so how do we get to
good pronunciation in the language
well i think there are three elements
one is the attitude
towards pronunciation i'll explain that
the second thing is the most important
things that we can do
that will give us good pronunciation and
the third thing is you know
remedial things if we have what we
consider to be poor pronunciation what
can we do
so
first of all
i think the attitude is overwhelming
in other words the people who pronounce
well have the right attitude
i've said this before
people who are able to get outside of
their own culture
and get into another culture
so i mentioned for example professional
athletes who are part of a team they
want to belong to the team they're going
to end up speaking like the other people
on the team
whereas say an intellectual like a
professor
is less inclined to do that tends to
stay more within his his own culture
we have to get outside of ourselves
that's why for example actors and
actresses are very good at imitating
accents because their whole profession
consists of imitating someone else
another role they can project themselves
into another role
so
you know we have to have that attitude
i've called it cultural weightlessness
i'm not for example me an
english-speaking canadian trying to
learn arabic i want to be with them i
want to be part of their culture or
persian or french or japanese or
whatever the case may be we have to be
able to project ourselves to pretend
that we are this other person and if we
hang back in our own culture
the more we hang back the more we
sort of see ourselves as almost a
representative of that culture
as opposed to just being a person of no
defined
you know
identity learning this new language
the poor we do we have to get outside
that so that's
number one
attitude
number two is
what are the steps that are going to
give us good pronunciation
i think the biggest thing is
listening
when i start a new language and
inevitably in these books they'll have
you know pages devoted to the
pronunciation of the language i spend
very little time on that mostly i want
to understand the value of the letters
so is the letter c
uh so
those are some of the things that i may
not pick up the first time i listen so i
kind of scan through it
some of the letters the vowels the
description of the vowels
it's kind of meaningless until i start
to hear it i have never
bothered to learn the international
phonetic alphabet i don't find it useful
because i know that i'm going to have to
do so much listening
in order to get a sense of the
pronunciation that
it's not really necessary to
to
focus on the ipa and the ipa would
probably represent some standard form of
pronunciation which maybe what i'm
listening to it doesn't correspond to
that anyway so to me that's not a useful
place to spend your time you have to
spend a lot of time listening
there was i someone on my twitter feed
mentioned i think she's an english
teacher in prague
that she had a girl in her class who had
wonderful american-like pronunciation
and the reason was that she has spent a
lot of time watching american television
programs
in the original
and uh you know in sweden everyone
pronounces well and it's because the
kids listen to a lot of tv programs in
the original so i personally don't think
there's any advantage in starting to
speak early and producing the language
early because i think there is a
a danger and i haven't been able to sort
of prove this through any research but i
think there is a danger that obviously
when we haven't heard a lot of the
language it's very difficult to
pronounce it correctly and so we
possibly
ingrain certain pronunciations that are
based on our native language because
that's all we have as a point of
reference
and uh
and so
until we've heard enough of it we start
producing it incorrectly and now we have
to change those pronunciations
you know in order to get closer to
the way the language is actually
pronounced
so
i mean if you had
the opportunity to spend six months
improving your language enough improving
your vocabulary enough that you could
actually enjoyably watch
television program soap operas movies
whatever
listen to podcasts in
the target language
and you didn't speak
and then you started speaking
your pronunciation will be better
than it would have been at the very
beginning before you had heard a lot of
the language
so
i think
a tremendous emphasis should be
placed on massive listening and and
because
why would you if you hear the word
pronounced a certain way
why wouldn't you pronounce it that way
when it's time for you to pronounce it
why would you pronounce it some other
way
in most cases it's not that we are
incapable of producing the sound
it's that we identify we see a word and
for whatever reason it triggers a
certain pronunciation based largely on
our own language yeah there are some
sounds that are difficult to pronounce
in every language there are a few sounds
that are difficult to pronounce and we
never we may never be able to pronounce
them correctly
but most of the sounds we have
and so why aren't we using those sounds
why as i often mentioned my father who
was born in czechoslovakia or was you
know the austro-hungarian empire when he
was born he would say nova scotia
instead of nova scotia
s-c-o-t-i-a it's a province in canada
he heard it all the time that he would
always say nova scotia it's not that he
can't say scotia but for whatever reason
in his mind it's scotia so i think there
are many examples of that where we are
capable of making the sounds but
for whatever reason because we didn't
get enough exposure to the language
before we started speaking we see a word
it triggers that reaction and bear in
mind like especially in english and i'm
finding that in arabic and persian
i have trouble pronouncing a word that i
haven't seen before
so
because the la the value of the letters
can change in persian it's
[Music]
you know they don't have vowels it's
just very difficult to pronounce a word
that i haven't seen before so i end up
relying
on my memory of how the word is
pronounced if i see a word if i see a
new word i'm guessing it how it's
pronounced but hopefully i'll hear it
often enough that i'll be able to
pronounce it but what is driving my
pronunciation is what i hear
and so i think we have to devote a lot
of time to a lot of listening so that
the brain just assimilates it it becomes
natural this is naturally how it's
pronounced now if you do all of this
listening
you're still not going to be like a
native because there will be
sounds that we can't produce like who in
swedish or there's a whole number of
these in different languages that are
difficult to pronounce
um
but and even if we are imitating what we
heard or what we
think we hear it's never going to be a
hundred percent
and
i mean i have dealt with so many
non-native speakers of english who speak
english very very well
but i can't think of any person who
learned the language as an adult who is
genuinely can be mistaken for a native
those people are so rare as to not
really matter
overwhelmingly you're going to develop
with through a lot of listening
good pronunciation good enough easily
understood
now the final thing is if you though
still aren't satisfied with your
pronunciation are there some things you
can do well obviously again listening
and then
reading something listening to it
reading it recording yourself and
comparing comparing not only for the
pronunciation of the individual word but
also
of the tone of the intonation listen to
yourself see
this trains your brain to hear how your
pronunciation is different from the
native and then go back and listen again
and
try to notice these things when you're
doing your
uh you know listening for pleasure
so reading out loud can help
um as i say recording yourself and
comparing yourself to the native speaker
with a particular emphasis on intonation
but
don't spend too much time on this
because this is going to make you
self-conscious
that i go back to the first
condition which is your attitude if you
are relaxed if you are comfortable
if you enjoy speaking the language if
you can picture yourself as just being
part of this other group where you're
just communicating for the purpose of
communicating if you do that without a
sense of pressure you will pronounce
well enough you won't be mistaken for a
native but you will achieve what i
always strive to achieve in any language
and that is to be comfortably understood
by the people i'm speaking to anyway
that's what i have to say on
pronunciation bye for now